let's talk about the artists today right
a lot of artists are out new uh new ones
that are part of our generation that
have grown what is your mindset with the
state of rap now I think it's fire
um it's a whole different
ballgame you know I mean like like whole
different crop of young superstars and
and uh Styles you know I mean
um I think
to me the the I've been feeling like
this for like maybe a year or two it's
like
I hate to say it almost because it
sounds like almost like pandering but I
really do think like man
there's a lot of fire female rappers and
it's like they I feel like they're doing
satellite painters yeah I feel like
they're doing some of the most exciting
commercially they're doing some of the
most exciting they're giving us a lot of
fire moments you know I mean and I feel
like that's something that wasn't around
the volume was never it was never like
that you always had a one a little kid
yeah
it could never be more than one almost
it felt like now it's like bro we
getting moments and moments and moments
I think that's hard
um it's over to hear you say that too I
mean you know I know that there's a
conversation of course attached
um two female rappers from female
rappers of just like wanting the support
from many and there's a thing of like
well you know we are saying the same
things that men saying we don't want the
feedback or you know to to receive
backlash uh then they were embracing the
craft so to hear you Embrace what
they're doing I know probably means the
world to them and honestly just to be
current and see that like that's
something that not being in the business
that I see
um what about mail where you at with the
the the males that are out there or it's
a good time
um and are you in I guess you could say
are you in a space where you have acted
as a voice mentoring are you available
I'm available like I made the decision
like maybe
I don't know I don't know how long ago
it was now but it was some years ago
where I was like because I when I came
in I was very much like I was so
competitive it was like everything was
Close Quarter I'm like I'm we not
friends so it's like you know me I'm not
gonna sit here and
fake it boom boom I was I was very much
on my own trying to get to where I was
trying to go and I realized
um I was like oh I turned around I was
like oh wait like because I started
thinking about
the end I started thinking about a day
when it's like brah like I love doing
this now but I don't know if I wanna
I don't know if I want to be doing this
forever you know what I mean so the
thought of the of an ending started
coming in my mind so then the thought
was you know if you if you if you were
to end and this was to be your last
album this would be your last one boom
like what who did you work with who did
you form a bond with who did you have a
lasting memory with and that like kind
of woke me up where it was like bro you
like you've been too closed off so I
purposely just started opening myself up
so when I meet somebody
you could have just came out boom boom
I'll meet with you we have a good
conversation bro take my line boom boom
hit me wrong so I was like I've been
that person way more over the past few
years yo take my line hit me reach out
so I've had great moments with artists
uh and up and coming I mean it was dope
there was something that I think it's a
it's a small thing that become the
biggest right that show that you're in
tune more importantly with understanding
the hustle understanding what an
opportunity looks and feels like and
sometimes being a part of that
springboard launch pad or whatever
um speaks more volume than the money or
financial backing it's it's the effort
of support it's the the idea of being
present